ليله تاريخيه في انتظار كل محبين الفنان
السعودي الراحل صوت الارض طلال مداح ليله
تكريم صوت الارض اللي راح تكون الاضخم
فنيه في العالم كان اعلن عنا سابقا رئيس
هيئه الترفيه تركي ال الشيخ واعتبر مشاركه
اي فنان فيها تكريم خاص
للراحل ومن بعد الاعلان عن ليله صوت الارض
السابق الفنانين للمشاركه فيها من قبل حتى
ما يتم تحديد موعد اليوم اللي راح تكون
فيه وصل عددهم الا عشرات الفنانين
والفنانات من مختلف الدول العربيه واما عن
اليوم المحدد فهو الاول من فبراير وكان
رئيس هيئه الترفيه تركي ال الشيخ نشر
تغريده اكد فيها على طرح تذاكر الحفل انها
ليله التاريخ
وترحل صرخه
للتاريخ ولتكريم بعد 22 عاما على رحيله
ايقونه الفن السعوديه والعربي ورصيد عشقا
وحب تزايد في حياته وبعد رحيله
ولاننا في نهضه غير مسبوقه في عهد مولاي
خادم الحرمين حفظه الله و سيدي ولي العهد
رئيس مجلس الوزراء قائدنا الملهم وعراب
رؤيه 2030 في بادره الهيئه العامه للترفيه
لتكريم صوت الارض طلع الماده
راجعون
[موسيقى]
انا راجع
اشوف
النجوم وبشكل يفوق الخيال ومن كل الوطن
العربي للمشاركه والحضور في عرس فني ضخم
وفي ليله لا تنسى عنوانها الوفاء لصوت
الارض